- [Shanahan:] Four years ago, I had Patty Mahomes on the ropes.
Back then, if I had the lead in the Big Game...
Check.
[Shanahan:] I simply stopped trying to score.
- Ummm, are Aces good?
- I... I fold.
- Yay!
- We will be back here with a vengeance.
- [Shanahan:] A lot can change in four years.
Chiefs went from lovable underdogs...
...to taking over the house that ALWAYS wins.
- Putting together a team to take back
what's ours.
- RIGHT ON, BROTHER.
- Oh, not like that.
[Shanahan:] Deebo, you play slot, and stay in motion.
And Kittle will be secretly mic'ed up so he can quietly let us know what's going on.
- Okay, so we've snuck into enemy territory,
but I don't think they suspect anything.
- [Shanahan:] CMC, we'll need you to go on a big run.
- I have 25 6s!
- [Shanahan:] Then you all put pressure on him.
- I wouldn't do that if I were you.
It's against the law.
- What law?
- The Greenlaw.
- There's too much heat on us.
We need someone they won't expect. A real nobody.
Someone...irrelevant.
- I know just the guy.
- Purdy, isn’t it?
It's the man! Scramble!
- How'd you like to make a lot of money?
Well, league minimum.
You son of a coach.
I’m in.
- [Shanahan:] We had to be careful.
They'd shored up their defense
over the years.
And she was always watching.
But while they were distracted,
Purdy scampered in.
- Pa-check.
- Juszczyk.
- No, JUS-zczyk.
- Lucky ol' Brock Purdy must have just gotten dealt a good hand.
- Pay that man his money.
Like, y’all should really extend him.
- [Shanahan:] But could he go head to head with
Patty MVP?
In the Big Game,
you can only play it safe for so long.
- I'm going for it.
- Not so fast, Chief.
I call.
- You don't have to call.
- [Announcer:] Rejoice Millennials, it's USHER!
- You know, they wouldn't even be in that game if it weren't for us.
- Also, everyone likes to pretend it's Mahomes vs. Purdy.
They literally never play at the same
time.
- Right? We're the ones facing Purdy.
Wait, shhh.
SHE's watching.